players in our history leading us to
multiple World Series championships an
active member in the community be
hard-pressed to think of anyone more
beloved than David and you can imagine
how this is impacted the Red Sox
organization I know how it's impacted
many of you who are here who loved David
and it's a very difficult day for doing
the magician look Jordan was the news
because it went from you know like an
attempted attempted burglary and then
all of a sudden we see the video you're
like this looks a little bit different
then the detective vertically journalism
news and then when you saw everything
first well as I said it shocked us to
the core I can speak on behalf of John
and Tom and my partner is Dave and in
any and everyone in the front office
it was jarring
it was frankly stunning and terrifying
it was a horrific incident and our focus
right now our exclusive focus is on his
health and well-being and doing what we
can to support and to get back here in
Boston speaking of that or the Red Sox
also sending a doctor down and anything
else they're doing with the organization
just tell the man I could tell you that
we're doing everything we can to support
the family but I'm not going to go into
details on anything related to the
medical care beyond what I've already
said questions quickly can you describe
anything about the medical staff that
might be accompanying him back to Boston
and in the second question obviously
that means so much to Red Sox Nation
everyone here did he have a message for
Bostonians Red Sox Nation anyone who
spoke about him and sending their their
thoughts to see of a message for them
well I can tell you that their medical
professionals that are involved with the
transport that's all I'll say on that
and knowing David I think all of us can
imagine what what he would be saying to
Red Sox fans and his supporters
I won't speak for David Ortiz but I know
he's fighting and we hope and pray that
this will all be behind us speak about
just the chaotic moments it must have
been free personally yesterday to hear
this information with with so much going
on and he was so iconic and when we were
talking to fans today they said that he
rallied around the city and around
everybody
during my time during the marathon
bombings and now they want to rally
around him yeah I mean we all remember
that in 2013 when we needed David Ortiz
the most he was there for us in in late
April and so it's appropriate and
expected that this community would rally
around David when he needs us what was
difficult to gather information anytime
you have a chaotic situation it's
difficult but I think John Linda Tom we
were all in constant communication
starting around 9:30 10 o'clock at night
when we were first made aware of the the
incident and then in contact we've been
in constant contact ever since then and
the most important thing is the club
thanks by the way to the media for
understanding maybe we were a little bit
less responsive than we normally are
because it was important to us to know
but Our Lady of this information or
confirm anything that we didn't know to
be true so we're just trying to gather
information and work with the medical
team to focus on his as his health care
but it was difficult to get information
and and we're appreciative of everyone's
patience
I guess David Eddie just as well as you
guys know David well extremely difficult
I mean it's shocking when they get this
type of news and heard it last night at
the same time and you're just your heart
goes out immediately animated family it
was also difficult gathering information
that was accurate
so making sure we tried to get that but
we are all different type of indications
of what had taken place but just Jo
you're shaking Billy is what it comes
down to they hear this type of somebody
who's not only he's iconic but he's a
friend and when you hear that it should
just feel for him expand yeah
just echo Dave's sentiments it was it
was hectic it was scary I mean try to
accurate information was also extremely
difficult unfortunately we had you know
a couple people on the ground there who
were incredible and getting us some
information
and that really helped us and delay our
fears a little bit but you know we
understood it was a serious situation
and and we're just really you know our
prayers are with David and nobody you
know he just it's better soon I mean
everybody's worried about him he's
obviously everybody's big brother so it
was tough news to swallow
david has always been obviously very
approachable media player safety
well go first and be player safety and
security is always a paramount concern
to the Red Sox to Major League Baseball
by the GAR group does does a good job
focusing on that we've traveled to the
dominican extensively spent time down
there and we're grateful to everyone who
was on the scene last night we've got
David the care that he needed but now as
we as we move forward our focus and
thoughts are on his health and getting
him back here for continued treatment in
a sort of oh sorry any sort of a tribute
at the game tonight well I think we'll
certainly recognize what's what's
happened but our focus all day I can
tell you has been on his health and the
ability to try and transport him back to
Boston and focusing on those logistics
exclusive waivers
yeah just to follow up on your second
question I think you know there are
measures that we tried taking and we try
to educate our players but it's not just
limited to you know David nuisances or
bait once it's a problem that you know
you encounter in a lot of places with
high-profile athletes and the exposure
and and money that comes along with it
you know there are there there are
factors that play into that that are
sometimes are out of our control and so
we try to you know educate the players
as much as we can we hope this is just
an isolated incident but in David's case
and Sam we were able to speak to to me
I've left Tiffany a voicemail and we've
texted back and forth and she expressed
her gratitude specifically to Jonathan
Linda and to the members of the front
office who have been in touch with her
directly and she knows that we're here
for her and the
soon I think as much as anybody you've
been the organization as long as maybe
Davis been around a long time beyond
what he means to the team and what he
means as a baseball player how is this
kind of affected you emotionally because
you've known him for such a long time
and I'm sure I have a very
yeah it's emotional time you know I love
David Ortiz we all love David Ortiz so
telling my kids last night what had
happened was really difficult and I know
the same holds true for everyone up here
for ownership it's hard to express what
what David Ortiz means to the Boston Red
Sox and when you love someone there they
come in harm's way it's it's jarring but
you you have to put those emotions aside
and focus on what's necessary and at
this moment it's exclusively focusing
our efforts on doing everything we can
for for Tiffany and the kids and for
David and do what we can to help
and we're just grateful for everyone
else is helping out as well and also
will any of you guys address the team
because obviously a lot of those guys
played with it yeah I know
Alex David in any event in touch with
Alex and several of the players and to
those guys to talk about the plan for
communicating with the players
Alex will not talk to the players bottom
by the situation I think he already has
bought with some of them in an
individual basis but I mean just think
of how big of an impact he's had in the
city of Boston and he's obviously an
icon
you know the month Rushmore of Boston
athletes but he is the guy in in in the
Dominican Republic you know he's more
famous than any president you know like
people think of a Dominican Republic
they think David Ortiz I think Pedro
Martinez and that's coming from somebody
who's you know been exposed to Dominican
over the years and I've been all like by
the impact that he has I mean just going
to a restaurant or any president is
everybody loves them and he's just he's
that guy but he comes from the way he
treats people he treats everybody the
same which is incredible and so just I
know that the country itself is stirred
you know by by this by this incident and
it doesn't surprise me that so many
people have reached out already trying
to help and the president is the
ex-president was there as you mentioned
earlier so you know it's been an
outpouring of support form just really
quickly and for our spanish-speaking
audience would you be able to give us an
update in espanol por si Claro
well para precocity okay serum hey stay
on tomorrow we'll eat I'm gonna sit
awesome Celia pero esta entonces ella
testometer Ando ontraport a médico de
santo domingo que esta noche para tratar
lo the hotel el tow yo que regresar a
tabatin poha la si todo possibie NGO
quiere llegando meat emoji
thanks everybody
[Music]